por qué
[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magazine informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
william a valencia y aquí damos una
mirada en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad el papel del patrimonio
africano en los museos europeos se ha
convertido en una polémica contemporánea
el nuevo director del museo de la
historia de la migración en parís
crearme un giro a la propuesta
historiográfica de este importante
centro cultural en burkina pasó la
violencia yihadista se ha convertido en
un obstáculo para la educación de los
niños y la seguridad de los profesores
organizaciones de docentes tiene
acompañamiento psicológico y social en
las regiones más peligrosas del país
y en nigeria el sector textil se
consolida como uno de los más
importantes para la economía de los
jóvenes diseñadoras de modas en las
principales ciudades plantean real
presente con sus diseños las telas más
tradicionales de esta nación iniciamos
entonces con la información aquí en
áfrica siete días el museo de historia
de la migración de parís tiene un nuevo
director se trata del famoso escritor
pop de allá de 55 años su objetivo a la
cabeza de este espacio cultural es
debatir la colonización los efectos
sobre la memoria colectiva de los
pueblos un asunto que con frecuencia
provoca controversia en la sociedad
francesa y con respecto a la relación
del país con sus antiguas colonias este
enorme edificio es el museo de parís
dedicado a la historia de la inmigración
su nuevo director es el afamado autor
para pendía y que viene de una familia
franco senegalesa a principios de la
década de los treinta
este centro de memoria fue llamado museo
de las colonias sirvió como mínimo final
básicamente es el monumento de
propaganda colonial más grande de
francia
y sustituto por eso necesitamos explicar
lo que hay aquí usando tecnología para
mostrar la verdadera historia y
demostrar que no es un aspecto marginal
de nuestro pasado y presente es una
pieza central nacional michi tap subimos
ángel para pendía lleno está de acuerdo
con los postulados raciales que algunos
sectores de la sociedad francesa quieren
posicionar como valores universales y
para louis no es una posición que se
oponga a la iluminación y el
universalismo seguidismo kukutza
al contrario es una manera de tratar
este tema en serio
creemos que el universalismo no ha
sucedido para todos durante mucho tiempo
es universalismo incluyó únicamente a
hombres blancos por youtube lo aprendí
ayer saltó a la fama en 2008 con su
ensayo sobre la población negra de
francia en 2019 fue uno de los
organizadores de la exposición en el
museo 12 sobre modelos negros en la
historia del arte y justamente hablando
del arte africano en los museos europeos
un documental grabado en la república
democrática del congo plantea esta
discusión y llama la atención de la
crítica la obra se titula white
qué significa cubo blanco y su autor es
el documentalista renzo martens natural
de países bajos realmente hablamos con
él desde ámsterdam y nos contó sobre
esta importante pieza que y la discusión
contemporánea sobre el arte africano
white cube hola soy rezo martes y acabo
de hacer una película que se llama
whitecaps y en ella se ve a los
trabajadores de las plantaciones
congoleñas irene khan ga booking para la
its matthew cast llamado quienes están
haciendo arte hermosas esculturas que
venden y con el dinero de sus ventas
compran su propia tierra y en esa tierra
han construido un museo que es realmente
importante
porque muchos de los hermosos deseos de
arte que conocemos han sido financiados
han sido fundados con el dinero
sustraído robado de las plantaciones
ahora muchos de estos museos se estan
descolonizando convirtiéndose en
inclusivos y diversos lo que es
realmente estupendo y debería haberse
hecho hace mucho tiempo pero sería aún
más importante que la plantación de la
que se sacó el dinero para construir
esos museos también se descolonizar
también se convirtieran inclusiva y
diversa
y eso es exactamente lo que están
haciendo matthew acá se llama un buque
kim para la e irene
con el dinero que obtienen del mundo del
arte están plantando árboles para su
propia supervivencia y la de toda la
humanidad están descolonizando la
plantación y todo esto se puede ver en
walter de colo night in translation no
los des gens y en guayaquil
hablamos ahora de burkina faso porque
esa nación de áfrica occidental enfrenta
la violencia yihadista que afecta tanto
a estudiantes como a docentes cuyos
menores se han visto obligados a dejar
sus estudios al salir desplazados y
algunos docentes intentan superar el
estrés postraumático provocado por los
ataques
son las ocho y media de la mañana y como
todas la mañanas y para emigrar a
escuela a los catorce años está en la
casa 2 y tiene dos años de retraso
porque bryant no es un estudiante como
los demás en 2019 con tu familia tuvo
que huir de su aldea en israel atacada
por hombres armados e incluso hoy le
recuerda cuando los yihadistas atacaron
nuestra aldea yo estaba en la escuela y
huí para advertir a mis padres a los
profesores también con el objetivo de
los grupos y artistas desde intimidación
amenaza hasta asesinato a la máquina del
software en la mañana del 3 de marzo dos
atacantes en motocicletas irrumpieron en
el pueblo y mataron a dos personas el
director de la escuela pública y un
residente esto provocó el cierre de más
de 2.000 escuelas principalmente en el
norte y este de burkina pasó incluso a
india algunos profesores de la región de
israel son víctimas de la inseguridad
este el caso de esa mira cuando una
mañana hombre armados llegaron a su
escuela
hoy si escuchó el sonido de una
motocicleta grande ya no soy yo estuve
dos semanas y dos días sin poder cerrar
los ojos
desde este ataque también es víctima del
síndrome de estrés post o matic o
consecuencias fisiológicas difíciles de
borrar dentro de este sindicato de
maestros abogan por el establecimiento
de un apoyo psicológico para los
maestros automatizados
dance de personas son forman muchos
profesores están traumatizados por la
situación e incluso cuando se reabrieron
sus escuelas no siempre recibieron apoyo
psicológico cuando fueron atacados
cuando fueron traumatizados para
estabilizarlos mentalmente para que
pudieran reanudar las elecciones de
manera serena full estabilice de empeño
y mental afecta y efecto y martín fuster
probable q razón serán si bien desde
hace un año está crisis de salud se ha
sumado a la crisis de seguridad desde el
último año escolar se han abierto 397
escuelas en burkina paso esto permitió
que casi 70 mil estudiantes se
reanudarán las lecciones hablamos ahora
de temas ambientales porque en el este
de camerún en los últimos años han
surgido decenas de yacimientos mineros
pero la fiebre del oro ha dañado
gravemente los cuerpos de agua de la
región el mercurio utilizado por las
entradas mineras ha dejado innumerables
puestos abiertos que se han convertido
en trampas mortales para la fauna varios
hipopótamos han perdido la vida en el
río cádiz desde julio de 2020
los activistas ambientales
sobre esta amenaza a la biodiversidad
a cielo abierto en la ribera de un río
este es uno de los innumerables sitios
de extracción de oro a lo largo del río
cada hogar de uno de los últimos si
votamos en el este de camerún
y la población de hipopótamos en el este
de camerún está en peligro de extinción
después de varias horas sólo unos pocos
levantan la cabeza por encima del agua
aquí
justin chico va director de una ong de
conservación de la naturaleza está en el
río para contar los animales hoy sólo
quedan unos 20 en comparación con los
100 que había 10 años atrás durante los
últimos seis meses tres fueron
encontrados muertos aquí una activista
cree que las muertes están vinculadas a
las operaciones de extracción de oro
y el hipopótamo es una especie en
peligro de extinción cuya población está
disminuyendo drásticamente en camerún y
en áfrica central debido al aumento de
las actividades mineras en esta área su
hábitat se ha vuelto muy frágil
este local filmó el cadáver del último
hipopótamo que murió junto al agua hace
unas semanas la comunidad está
preocupada
nos sentimos incómodos porque si los
hipopótamos continúan muriendo incluso
nuestros hermanos menores nuestros
nietos y nuestros hijos no tendrán la
oportunidad de verlos
neuron tributando igual el tipo los
conservacionistas dicen que el mercurio
es la principal causa de la muerte de
los hipopótamos varias empresas mineras
de la región derraman la sustancia
tóxica en el río jeaustin analiza la
calidad del agua con regularidad y
evidencia cuán dañino es el mercurio
para este hábitat
a la contaminación del agua es muy alta
por lo que no es buena para los peces y
los hipopótamos que viven en ella las
actividades mineras han contaminado su
hábitat
podemos ver diferentes aceites en este
cuerpo de agua donde estas actividades
contribuyen a la contaminación de esta
agua
los ecologistas han encendido la alarma
señalando el devastador costo de la
fiebre del oro para la invaluable
biodiversidad de la zona
y pasamos al mundo de la moda porque los
diseñadores nigerianos han decidido
romper el molde y en lugar de producir
ropa genérica han optado por trabajar
con textiles tradicionales utilizando
técnicas artesanales son parte de una
tendencia que apunta a utilizar
materiales tradicionales nigerianos para
crear atuendos modernos veamos
este taller de moda en lagos vibra con
el sonido de las máquinas de coser
mientras los diseños de sema divinity
cobran vida
mi nombre es benítez y soy diseñador de
moda cruce de en lagos nigeria sabor
trabajo con una tela tradicional
nigeriana hecha a mano llamada show que
ha hecho que es una tela tejida a mano
por integrantes del pueblo yoruba
históricamente se usa en ocasiones
especiales y benítez quería asegurarse
de que la generación más joven se sienta
orgullosa de esta herencia
estamos preservando la cultura para
nosotros la estética es parte importante
de la identidad aquí en las bodas tienen
toneladas y toneladas de este tipo de
tela así que estamos tratando de hacerlo
de nuevo y de alguna manera enseñarle a
la generación más joven que es algo de
lo cual estar orgullosos para que ellos
también lo quieran usar las prendas de
esta colección personalizada cuestan
entre 300 y 4.000 dólares
la diseñadora de lagos lisa polo you se
especializa en un tipo diferente de tela
estas se llaman cara su colección se
llama bad cara ya que incorpora diseño
es batik en el producto final
siempre trato de usar nuestras telas
locales además de sedas y otros tejidos
o texturas para crear siluetas modernas
y moda que va más allá de los límites
fashion art ha sido es dion bound suisse
las empresas han respondido a este
cambio en la moda africana la industria
está creciendo y es cada vez más
relevante para el estilo de vida de las
personas antes la gente usaba ropa trae
sólo en ocasiones especiales o es
simplemente para ir a la iglesia o para
sus bodas ahora estamos pensando en el
lujo africano en términos cotidianos día
a día esta nueva generación de
diseñadores también espera que la
promoción de estas prendas y patrones
ayude a empoderar a los artesanos
locales y garantizar que se continúe
transmitiendo el conocimiento
y finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días con música de la cantante
nacida en gabonés channel y su nuevo
videoclip titulado ok ok de esta canción
la artista revela los errores de su
esposo y como la pareja ha logrado
superar los obstáculos propios de la
vida en convivencia así finalizamos este
capítulo de áfrica siete días siempre al
24 porque ustedes pueden también visitar
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
para ampliar la información de américa
latina y el mundo quédense con nosotros
estos france24
[Música]
sí
a mí
[Música]
eso consiguieron